hey guys I am back it's been a while
since I've done like a normal chest
stream the last two streams I've done
one was on top of a mountain and the
other was while I was kayaking so now
I'm finally in my natural habitat which
is indoors in front of a computer on
leach s so hopefully this will be a be
fun and instructive and hopefully I'll
get a chance to play some people who
want to play me mute okay just want to
make sure it's working all you go sounds
good actually I wonder if I can okay do
I have follow alerts happening
mm hey okay I have follower alerts
Jennifer to was an old follow that's
happened a few days ago but okay it
should be working
hey it's a cheer from Acer bait Thank
You Acer baits
and hello to more people hello Manas
good to see you
hello your uranium-235 hello ed sweets
okay so I'm gonna just challenge people
or just start games let's start a game
let's just play this guy he's seeking an
11 minute game which is a nice time
control gives me enough time to think
sip my tea
Thank You Pedro sky GG for the follow of
the first actual follow of today is a
sky present is about 10 seconds to move
em singer in the chats hello I'm singer
hello Franco lope hello ref Raqqah good
to see all you all you beautiful people
um too bad for this guy either it was
too scared or he's just not here that's
kind of sad
okay well play this guy I come from
Tetris 10+2 okay make sure I can see
everything and let's play let's play e4
I'll take opening suggestions so if
people want to see a certain opening
just let me know if I don't acknowledge
it let me know multiple times I'll try
and play something interesting he's
playing something boring thank you see
the Royal 8th for the follow let's play
d4 hearing d4 is an ambitious move
attempt to make things dynamic as
quickly as possible but now I have to
remember it's a line here
the pond there's already Bishop c5 I
have to be careful but I take with 932 i
play Bishop d3 I play Bishop d3
something like d5 and then I take your
liking castle in one move
I really haven't studied this I just
know d4 is is one of the main lines
hello excise sparks long time no see
Tama we're with the uptime I'm only 1600
on each house any suggestions how to
improve thanks for subbing I'm singer
um I'm gonna actually recorded video I
have it on my to-do list this week about
how to improve at chess cuz I get this
question so often like people will give
me their rating and say how to improve
and it's a generic question but I feel
like there's there's many things I say
over and over again which is kind of
general advice but but hopefully
practical advice I'll put in into one
YouTube video this was castle here but
well I can tell you is okay so you're
1,600 um I mean you you have to keep a
passion for the game like you have to
enjoy the learning process I think is
really important of course it's fun to
win but you really have to enjoy the
process of learning and this could
involve playing stronger players and
losing and then going back and seeing
how you can improve on your weaknesses
but there's okay there's so many ways to
improve at chess so a polar bear system
is getting spammed in the chat
uh like white should win material here
if I really want I can take on each
seven and when the pawn but I don't know
if I want to win that H pawn
play Bishop Bishop c4 Knight b6 buy c4
and then Knight c3
I don't know
I also don't want to overthink this I'm
just gonna play c4 and a complete
development I'll put my knight on c3
I'm not winning a pawn because I want to
develop activate my pieces Tom Lehrer is
asking if I'm in the US I'm in Prague
but I'll be in the u.s. relatively soon
but the bishop I need for
Prague is our really nice City I've only
been here for a day but it's some this
is a the environment here the vibe is so
nice food is good people are nice
relatively clean
please compared to other cities I've
been to by the way what is a polar bear
system I know it starts with F 4 is it
just like a reverse Leningrad my forking
him a 396 is forced be for us to move
the bishop and then be 5i for Kim
that's nice just a matter of moving
pawns until I win a minor piece
I don't think he can prevent this unless
he can I mean Bishop b6 would be funny
man I could trap him or I could for him
now life is good
exei sparks bought the HS London study
HS London course it's an eight-hour
video course which I really haven't
promoted too much but thanks for
purchasing it um if anyone else has
bought the course if you have questions
if you have feedback let me know because
there's a good chance I'll make another
course relatively soon on another one of
my favourite openings okay so here white
is just up a piece
uh and I have better pieces or better
development better pieces maybe he'll
fall for some Greek gift these castle
only 2500 feet a and you stalled in your
development how do you improve you have
to improve by adding some more more
cores more processing power
maybe update the software
okay good game I come from Tetris was
only 12 moves
why is remate rematch greyed out sorry
for wasting my time well hopefully
people enjoyed that I don't know this
beautiful opening preparation
there is no sorry in chess Gigi okay
thanks for the game I was about to say
Gigi but probably wasn't a great game
yeah what is the theory here as I recall
some line where there is some really
early bishop take f7 I think Gary played
it very Gary game just go through the
main line
take
maybe was at this 95 now this is
something else
but did Gary play Gary lost in like 20
moves 16 moves
I'm forgetting
was it this first b5
this is actually bugging me now because
I remember there is some really cool
line
nopal Mian Shi game because I know Nepal
Meucci was playing this yeah 92 there's
some other line anyone in the chat know
what I'm talking about
if anyone then the chat knows what I'm
talking about there's a Giri game in
this slide I'm pretty sure it's after D
for wear white somehow socks on a sudden
early
I forget if Curia was white or black it
was a really cool type of line um anyway
I'll respond to people it's hard to keep
up you just watch my video on the petrov
nice a spawn it's going well
I don't rating shame people because it
makes them feel bad
but if you're offering like practical
advice then continue to do that what
support would be the funniest OHS come
to Bulgaria I met the top Bulgarian
streamer in Romania probably the only
Bulgarian chess streamer
do some random exchange place yeah I'm
smart enough to not give away my money
for free but thanks for the advice
thank you tile MC n for the father for
the for the sub four months in a row
Thank You tile
uh we're about were you in Spain I was
in Venice K and then I was in Barcelona
um Belgian novice for two months in a
row thank you Belgian novice okay I'll
accept some challenges am i ignoring -
I'm sorry if I'm informing people it's
difficult to keep up
very difficult
okay let's accept someone
and the singer loves me even when I'm
not yelling
you want me to be yelling okay um Omanis
I have a question for you actually have
a question on behalf of someone else
well let's start another game though
what's the longest time in troll here
let's play this guy I'm not always going
to accept the longest time control but
it's just convenient is it lagging
I think it's lagging again sorry if it's
lagging let's play a London
okay now it's I think it's okay
sometimes if I have too many tabs open
it starts lagging we're gonna play a
London because this is my bread and
butter
output coupler with a sub so many subs
today probably because I haven't
streamed in like a month at least on a
normal stream in about a month
you
London prep raises Cara Juana
oh it was my London prep oh that's nice
forgot about that those good memories
well let's play c3 here I the game in
this in the last round of the Benassi
open I played this move order with c3 in
92 we'll see how much Theory he knows
being just below 1,400
x/i sparks just said London hike yeah
I played the London so much my
throughout the Europe trip in these
tournaments sadly I lost twice in London
once to a GM and then once to some lower
rated player but in both of those games
I had good openings Bishop f5 this is
actually a line I was studying recently
because I usually play a different move
order which basically prevents Bishop f5
but this is playable I think Queen b3 is
a move and then if he ever takes on d4
and we trade this will transpose to the
most recent game I played and the last
round of the tournament in Spain but in
this case I think he's just giving me a
free pawn
that's just a free pawn thank you for
the 50 bits extra kuhar
people are so generous when I play the
London
been trying to catch me live for a while
I haven't been life in a while it's okay
this guy is facepalming himself
uh it happens
Ches
sometimes you put yourself in situations
where you're facepalm yourself but
that's how you learn Bishop b5 is coming
not really calculating I'm just assuming
that I'm winning more material somehow
because how does he defend he has to
play this
maybe I should have played mission a six
I would have trapped the rook
hmm well I can still play Bishop a6
right
takes I take Brooke you know he can't
play trick to you because I am talking
to things
so best move anything better good enough
znation chess with the sub
I think znation chess was my first ever
subscriber so I don't think anyone can
be his his nine-month streak Thank You C
nation by the way congratulations to Z
nation as giving z nation some some
moral supports during the world
open run congrats e nation for a good
performance
hope you've recovered from the emotional
stress just can be very stressful
tamo we're did I just ignore your
challenge also Manas let me not ignore
Manas the wiki page I was crying trying
to create got rejected
they have a large they gave a large
number of reasons that's sad
he resigns because this is coming
yeah
another sub from something Orly Thank
You Hurley
uh we'll accept someone else
wait waiting for my question oh yeah I
had a question okay let me accept
another challenge you also I'll accept
Tamil year she was the first challenger
meeting at 2:00 it's 10:40 3 p.m. so if
you have a meeting at 2:00
I assume that's it's probably Pacific
time
ok my question is on behalf of AGM let's
place the ceiling so I was listening to
the perpetual chest podcast today I was
taking a long walk through the city of
Prague thank you tile I'm CN for the
bits I was listening to the interview
with Paco Vallejo it was another leech a
streamer and he was saying that he had
some issue with twitch he applied for a
partnership and they never applied to
him so then he stopped streaming because
they weren't replying and then they
rejected his partnership uh because he
stopped but he stopped because twitch
support wasn't replying so mana I don't
know if you have the right connections
but Vallejo by far deserves partnership
with twitch he's like top seed like top
50 top hundred in the world so I don't
know what connections you have but
he was I think it would be it would be
favorable for everyone if he would start
streaming again because we were having
some interesting battles I would
recommend that you just listen to an
interview because he has some really
interesting stories
he recently played an event with Wesley
so and prog Ananda was some cool stuff
do you have his twitch username it's
findable on the Lee chest streamers I
don't know it off the top of my hand
hand top of my head I think it's GM
Vallejo or something like that
how strong is prego prego is a youngest
GM in the world second youngest in
history who I met not too long ago in
Australia strong player
you
are there mods it should be mods
let's mod - even though you're leaving
soon MA - gosh what's your name though -
Paul day
you have like although mod power or
automatic mod powers if your that wasn't
even the command you're already a mod
are you just a mod on everyone's stream
you
Oh interesting
ckx i @c k XE thank you for the sub all
the people subbing with twitch crime
on all streams well now you have the mod
symbol which I don't think you had
before
anyway let's give some commentary here
we have a time on of line if if anyone
plays this is white you should know
tonight b5 is the best move a lot of
people go wrong my fish of e3 or Bishop
e2 which runs into Bishop b4
you
hello Dan nine one zero seven one two
wait it's my move
what am i doing I'm getting like so
intrigued by the chat forgetting I'm
playing a game this is usually a good
structure for black especially because
he's played f4 so early I would like to
play Bishop c5 or Queen b6 and just
prevent him from castling let's start
with Bishop c5 I'm also preventing
Bishop e3
do you mind if I share this video I
would mind because
I don't think I
said like exactly the correct situation
I would recommend share the clip of the
podcast and that I can just send you I
could just send you like the the
timestamp of the podcast where he talks
about the situation with twitch
give me like a day for that so anyway
I'm going to play a five because I want
to play Bishop a six
like Bishop a6 my bishops will be
working together and this Queen is a bit
actually as Queen might come to g3
and then if I Castle
the position should still be good
there's so many comments it's hard to
keep up with everyone dan is asking how
to challenge you can challenge me on me
chess
and to do that you go to my leech s
profile there should be a leech s
command maybe someone could see type
exclamation points leech s need like
with we need Nathan or axe villager to
manage the commands
there we go yeah you can just go to the
link that nightbot shared
you
exei sparks asking why am I not
streaming often
wait did exercise sparks say that to me
or is Monas asking excise bark set to
answer that from my perspective I Owen
screamed often because I played
back-to-back tournaments in Romanian
Spain and I was relying on my internet
my my mobile hotspots wait why did I not
play Bishop a6
Oh cuz I played rugby instead
to the throne in Bishop a6 I'll play
Queen b6 9a for Bishop f2
I'll just castle
this is kind of just turning into a an
interactive stream interacting with the
chat while trying to play a chess game
at some point I'll try and focus more on
the chat or it more more on the chess
Bishop III
three is a good move I'm just gonna take
and place c5 and I'm expanding with
tempo because I'll be threatening d4
you can't you still can't castle
maybe I'll try and improve my queen
somehow
we'll see
dan you can challenge me at any time
control probably what I'll do for the
next game is I'll just pick someone at
random right now I have 13 pending
challenges
so other people want to play and then
I'll probably just give Siri or tell
Siri to pick a random number
so Siri will control our destiny
it's like Queen b6
you could probably get away with
castling
kingside
I'm trying to discourage him
but
castle see for king each one
oh that maybe I play d4 and c3 keep
pushing pawns I could pick a random sub
how do I pick a random sub
also pick a random follower
Thank You burns Lee
and rain for the follow
interesting name
you fbi's something something something
for the follow
Tropius for the follow
interesting names oh I could just pick a
singer mm singer deserves a game I'm
gonna try and be around for a while to
try and get as many games as possible
the only issue is that
I might be playing a tournament tomorrow
morning
the tournament is like an hour and a
half away from where I am I might have
to wake up in like seven hours we'll see
okay so I wanted to go for this sort of
stuff I'm going to start with Bishop d7
because I don't want him to access this
e4 square I want to be able to play d4
and not allow Knight e4
I think that's logical
it's difficult to yeah to just know who
the subs are
to start doing this again when I have
like subscriber Sunday streams or
whatever just for subs
um if you're a sub and you're
challenging me and you want to gain use
the subscriber chat room there should be
another chat room where it just tell me
your your elite chest username and maybe
I'll give you some love
okay so now see 494
Spidy for
on eating the Beast
I mean he might just oh he can't play
Bishop f3 maybe he'll just play Knight
d6 and he'll try and win this beast when
I play Bishop d5
yeah thanks Moniz for four
thank you for that that would be awesome
because yeah I was listening to the
interview like a few hours ago and I was
thinking hmmm I should probably contact
mamas
um okay he wants to attack me on this
square I want to attack come on the
square
I five might be an interesting move
it's double-edged let's play r5
there's ups and downs - f5 if he doesn't
take then his Bishop is blocked and it's
harder for him to attack if he does take
I take I get my knight in into play he
no longer has access to d6 my e pawn
could be weak but then my knight could
come to some juicy square like this so
he plays Knight d6 which i think is
logical I'm going to keep my Bishop
I know him personally I know him
virtually we've had some pretty pretty
messy bullet battles
but never met him in person
yeah I learned a term recently it's
called a decoration in chess is just a
piece which is on a pretty-looking
square but it doesn't actually do
anything
okay now the knight is doing something
maybe I should keep the pawn defended
except it's attacked twice it's my queen
d8
he's playing a good game he didn't have
a great opening but
I probably mishandled the position now
he's winning upon but this bishop is
such a monster
and I don't care about pawns I care
about attack King h8 is actually the
first move of my attack because I want
to play rook GA g5 opened the G file and
target this spawn
the structure works very well against
suspicion
before was before looks like a free pawn
rook take before
wants a take-back he probably meant to
play b3 wait no his pong was on b3 I
don't think that was an acid less he
meant to play a four he says T why so
much he probably just forgot I could
take the pawn okay well no he wants to
come back and I'll if I play rook GA 96
is a bit annoying
you
maybe I started with Queenie seven or I
play rook to 96 97
I don't know start with rookie AIDS
as long as it's not bughouse as long as
he can
place the knight on f7 I'll be okay and
then I can do this
he's going to try and trade bishops
probably
interesting to put the bishop on e4
wait that's probably a blunder because
he
can take in 96 nice forking a bunch of
things
I can't even avoid the bishop trade
how am i losing to a 14
yeah he's no he's playing
playing good moves and I'm being a bit
careless
kind of workaround
the issues I could take take take take
words
I think it's a good idea to keep that
like all the tension I'm just gonna play
rook g7 someday I'll double up I'll let
him take if he wants to I'm a bit tilted
bit distracted have a long day
but I'm still competitive
I spent like a good hour and a half this
morning recording this YouTube video
someone sent me a link I think it was it
was blunder bus driver some some name
along those lines he sent me a link to
this website like a this ello meter test
website I spent an hour and a half like
completing the test
Gotham chess a long time no see Gotham
chess actually a Gotham chess I think I
saw part of your stream last night I was
drifting off and I checked twitch and I
may have fallen asleep to your stream
just because I was tired like the stream
was exciting I was just kind of tired c3
is a good move
um maybe I just just trade nights
this night is better than mine
a max pph saw that video
he doesn't want to trade nights
okay now I can play this
this is gonna get a bit messy we're both
gonna have really strong nights in each
other's territory I like to call this an
octopus because an octopus has eight
tentacles
octa-pie octa-pie are very strong rights
by losing upon can win this pawn take
take
take on f4 I could take on f4 and then
play 93
looks decent
first
I'm so indecisive I'm gonna take here
he's a long time there's a two second
increments so it will probably come down
to the wire you play more lively chess
on st. Louis Chess Club YouTube channel
I'm gonna see what I can do I want to
try some some things on their channel
I'll be back in st. Louis in August a
roof a neo or is it roof Anil oh thank
you for the sub spending so much time in
Spain I like to pronounce the double owl
as a why
but I do appreciate that
um
is it still Amazon Prime day is that why
everyone's subbing with Prime
or was that yesterday so confused all I
know is I have an octopus targeting g2
and he's long time
and I want to just increase pressure
again all my pieces now can attack I
don't care that he has three connected
pass pawns
I actually have no idea Oh Chris
Wainscott in the chat Gris Wainscott I
just see I see always commenting on
Facebook and Twitter I've never seen
them on twitch this is this is a rare
sighting of Chris the problem is if I
take on G to Grateful Dead things for
the son if I take on G to a bunch of
times he has a night left 7:00 in the
end and that would be painful so I think
I should take with the night wait what's
going on here so if I take here he still
has this hope he's not watching I'm just
giving him all all this free advice
Nathan with the sub nathan has been so
supportive the last several weeks Thank
You Nathan
you
this was raided okay I have to be
careful
it's hard to focus when so many people
are following and subbing
I'm singer is still here at Gotham is
here you tourism is here okay a queen g5
problem is the resource is so strong and
my nights hanging 2.95
any pawns I might down just don't to
pawns
completely 95 right away
I could just play a move and hope he
doesn't see the tactics but that's hope
chess
plain they take G
to
and set as it winds up on I'm only down
one pond
more stuff is happening
I take
I think this gives me enough camp
any five or c5 and I'm going to take on
g2
matrix in the chat is matrix well I
think matrix is the founder of the
founder of chess cata me
pretty sure that's that's who I think it
is
incuse another streamer too
hello to matrix retired bad chess player
a retired national master okay he didn't
see nine f7 so this is nice Gotham chess
with the sub gifted by Nathan Thank You
Nathan Thank You Gotham chess for
existing on this planet
I really didn't want to give up my
nights I do win his rook and now
okay now black should objectively be
better even though he still has three
pastors my rooks are going to coordinate
on on the G file and his King has no
shelter
you
wants to win you six
as king could do this
I'm threatening this and this my queen
and rooks are gonna has caused so much
devastation
coming
or is a mate there's mates good game
tomalley
also known as Tom earlier that was
I was actually an interesting game
light was probably much better at some
point especially
after winning the a pond
play was slow than Bishop yeah this
whole maneuver at Bishop e2 to f3 is
very what's the right word very strong
just neutralizes my bishop limits my
counter play but I did find some counter
play he should have played 9 f7 here I
was calculating something like this
night f7 take I assumed this would be
that I signed for whites and that I can
try and win back some pawns I could try
and exploit his King
this would still be interesting some
line like this where IRA can get active
maybe if I got really lucky I could meet
him
anyway people are challenging with 22
challenges maybe next time I shouldn't
name the stream challenge me then it's
just too much she named the stream like
don't challenge me I don't know what
happened then did someone donate someone
donated who donated
oh wow thank you I'm a singer for the
donation
I completely miss that
[Music]
stop abandoning us okay well now I'm
incentivized to stop abandoning you guys
let's give someone a game oh my gosh I
would give em singer again but I don't
know what his name is
okay I'm just gonna tell Siri to do
something Siri pick a random number
between 1 and 23 it's 20 to 22 okay
oh matrix you're so close
but it's this guy right 23 challenges
and yeah second-to-last
[Music]
okay
22 for its lire work good luck
let's fight you for know let's play a
London is so many London lovers here the
wired disturbance is dubious
is there a wire disturbance
someone is spying on me
Thwaites let me ask you guys a question
I'm gonna take the fun this anti London
can I ask you guys is there like
interference with the audio because I
was having this issue earlier where it
like it it's like radio interference
but I don't know if it's still happening
is it still happening
I'm so sorry
cell phone maybe I'll just throw my cell
phone
across the room
because when now let me know if it
happens because it happened when I
recorded earlier and I had to like go
back and try and delete stuff actually
let me put my phone on airplane mode
okay the phones on airplane mode this
wasn't happening at all like in the last
month since I've had my mic it's one of
these Samsung go mics I know people can
see this
you
Oh
testing is it back oh I'm losing because
there's no whom there's no increment oh
wait I have to defend the pawn it works
now right why was a input level not
showing up
there's no Oh inputs there we go okay
beautiful
if there's interference or more
interference let me know and I'll
troubleshoot I gotta play much quicker
because this is rated I don't want to
lose rating points but I also want to
thank Nathan for the hundred bits maybe
it's some blessing in disguise
okay so I'm down a minute but my moves
coming up are gonna be very simple
hopefully and just because I'm feeling
bad I'll probably play Nathan I'm matrix
next
because he was so close
like taking
for I don't think works let's take care
I have two bishops relatively open
position I'm not going to give a sigh
mole because that's difficult it's play
hid oh okay I'll play the doughy cuz
that's all caps from Gotham chess so it
has to be important
I'll play the Dewey
and then maybe I'll play matrix
oh my gosh I finally understand matrix
as two meanings mate tricks and matrix
like the movie mind blown
let's focus 29 seconds to bishops let's
put rooks in the center I want to do
this in this
please do this in this
I wonder if he is watching
might be just to hear all my inner
thoughts chief oh I can take
he was probably just thinking okay of
this smooth this is getting weird
that's hanging but he's pinned so this
is also hanging
such a weird position he just blundered
that
low on time
I'll be queen c3 is coming
I don't think he has much of an attack
this is kind of stuck
here comes a [ __ ] who's gonna flag me or
him that's a free bishop
you
I was thinking about this move with that
and then I get mated wait I really have
to focus here
am I just meeting him
g6
okay this is nice
hey queen up three mates okay that was
kind of close um the messiness somehow
went in my favor
let's find Hanoi how many ions does it
take to plug in a USB mic too many
okay where's her do i oh my gosh how do
i unhighlight everything no I don't to
click okay there we go
uh hadoo a ctrl-f enjoy there's a doughy
is with five bits we're playing a toy
and we're gonna play the polar bear I
have no idea what the polar bear is but
I know it starts with f4 and maybe it
involves c3
g3 and this
some people were talking about the polar
bear in the stainless chess club YouTube
live chat and they were saying how great
of an opening it is for blitz I think
it's a good opening just to gather fresh
position and to avoid theory
it's a toy Japanese
the origins
you
so this is probably some version of the
polar bear I remember looking at it once
I remember white doing weird stuff with
like eight or nine eighty-three like
some plan like this right and then
queenie one and eventually four
not sure how that helps at all
I'll see what happens
hmm Hanoi has some fans
or maybe just has
which she hanging on
I could maybe transpose to some
Stonewall make this Bishop really sad
maybe I'll play h3 at some point
see too
could do weird stuff like 93 or 94
I say I drew the arrows in a different
order then I said the squares I'm gonna
play a 94 here I'm not in the center
can't be a bad thing if he takes I
probably take with pawn
and if he moves the bishop maybe I can
somehow prepare f5
maybe I can play Knight e5 take take 97
night f3
yeah my knifes are happy this weird
position I like it
you
it's it's a rare opening yes it's a rare
animal as a little polar bear like just
about extinct
how many polar bears are there on the
planet maybe Siri will know oh but my
phone's in airplane mode and it's across
the room so it's said if someone can
tell me how many polar bears there are
on the planet I'm curious if there's
more polar bears on the planet or more
grandmasters on the planet so I feel
like both are pretty extinct
or endanger it not extinct
most extents
do I have another main weapon besides
the London I do I'm probably gonna make
a course on it over the coming months
but that will have to remain top secrets
I like my structure it's like a French
structure I'm gonna play Queenie one I
want to prepare an ith four
you
just to defend this pond
maybe I could play e3
mmm he's treating this like a French he
wants to play Queen b6 and apply
pressure here in here now night h4
doesn't make as much sense
I don't want to play III as the blocks
for the bishop
so I can calculate 9h 4 if you take sy
take Queen b6
queen f2 okay I'll go for it my knight
really doesn't have any other purpose we
need a polar bear emote
I still need to make a London emos the
problem is I can't make anymore emotes
because I don't have enough sub points I
mean I think I need to hit 50 subs or
something for another emotes lot of
maxed out
i exhausted all nine emotes unlike naka
and Sam's England Gaspar of it's sad
okay
Queen f2
I do have two sets of double pawns
that's true but there are good sets of
double pawns because they give me open
files to work with and they're not
really that weak because they can't be
attacked the play Bishop f3 preparing h5
and then I want to start targeting g7
Brooksie it's a good move he wants to
penetrate start with h5
even he if he gets rook c2 I'm not sure
what he's threatening
I get this in this
pretty sure I know what I would be
threatening
he's gonna do this at some points
can I just go absolutely crazy and sack
everything and maybe it's mate also okay
I forgot
he's a slightly good player didn't even
look at his rating
g7 King dg7 Bishop take age six
quinta gage six Queenie 3 GG 7
she won at any point he can give it back
a piece Lee bishop g6 it's difficult
so rook to g7 probably not good it's so
tempting though
play Queen g3 or g8
maybe I just start with rook G for the
the pond get ready to double up or even
triple up
yeah looks decent
I could go for the sack because it's
casual
it's also bad like objectively I want to
play objectively decent moves
well I forgot about there's a pin
well maybe now I go for the sack
change
rook take g7
wait this is troublesome because my d4
pawn could be lost
rook to g7 King to g7 Queen g3
it's quite troublesome
but what else to do
we work h4
that's no fun
okay this is really bad I'm gonna go for
the sack which maybe I should have
played before
hello the Super Stallion 99 thanks for
watching Daniel Moreno 99 yeah that's
the same person
okay this is going to be interesting
because we might try and be tricky here
Elevens
I got the very worst I'm losing exchange
very best his King is opening up
and I have two bishops
and miking is relatively safe
look on the bright side of things how
the from Germany nice well greetings
from from Czech Republic
not too far away from Germany Germany is
like really close within an hour or two
bus ride
okay let's play Queen g3 super VJ thanks
for the follow
he quickly played this I don't have to
take immediately unless I want to
let's start with
maybe I do take immediately as I have
some trick
take
to do this
whoa you really didn't want me to do
that
why it wasn't like life-threatening
now it's okay I'm just a lap on it's
like a very good version of what I
thought I was going to get
five
like h4 h5
yes he's double attacking two punts
defender is one
maybe I combine ideas like start with
Queenie v f6 as possible
yeah weird things happen
I'm gonna start with this
try and make him think also I'm long
time a little scratching magician thanks
for the follow
I did take care of my double pawns by
losing them
losing them both kind of sad
the good thing about having double pawns
or being down pawns is a fact that you
just have more open files
position I'm actually exploiting like
open file oh there's more more lines to
attack with
I just play h 5 h g1 h 5 bishop moves
somewhere rook g1 I guess he can take
and defend
you
hmm I don't want to like provoke Bishop
f5 because on these frightening Rick g8
so maybe I play Queenie five and then
this again it gets weird
if we want to hold on to this fun
I'll play Queenie five there's no
increment so time is really important
you
I'm getting message while my phone is in
airplane mode by the way our people
still oh my gosh I lost upon people are
in hearing like microphone interference
right
as that been solved hopefully
I hope
is it still wait when you say no it
hasn't been solved or it is okay there's
no interference that's good so I'm down
to pawns but there's no interference
play this or this
decisive maybe this
five
okay well I'm doing I'm flying down as
Bishop to f7 so when I play this it's a
real threat I'm actually not sure what
he's going to do here
or maybe I am sure I just don't want to
tell him in case he's watching
you
okay I'll look at the chats the spies
are gone that's good
372 IQ of that quote
yeah the best way to get rid of a
problem piece or problem pawn structure
is to blunder it
thanks for the sub
something-something
okay h5 is actually a good move
spectacular camel
okay I gotta focus there's no increments
I could bill outright with perpetual no
I can't
maybe just ripped g5
could bring the queen to e3
liking a safe on g-tube I think
you
weird position I'm a singer got good I
don't remember I'm singer being was good
I feel like he's been working with with
Gotham chess
last time I played I'm singer that's a
while ago
mmm what does this move
phone
but that's not actually a threat
I take here
and he has a check here
just do this he's safe
and everything I gotta move quicker hey
thanks Nathan for creating a cool
comments been asked a neither fisca
comment - or a FISA command
okay what is this
tick tick
mmm so complicated and so little time
let's put the King on each to getting
off the G file if you Wednesday for I
have to go all out probably take here
and pray for the best
please take the bishop
she don't know how to evaluate this
it's going to rely on
concrete lines
problem for him obviously he can't take
I'm not going to say anything I still
don't know what's going on
I know f7s a major targets that's
probably a good move
maybe I do this he's pretty passive he's
giving me more time what a generous
person donating subscribing
cheering giving me one more minute to
think now he's wanting to make a queen
for himself so maybe he's not that
generous
my breakthrough
you
something like there should be some kind
of breakthrough
when calculating bishop take g6 and then
h5 but no here's rook take g6
oh then I broke HF so okay Bishop to d6
pawn to g6 only move
each five
he just takes on each five
just
stuff
I have an idea III a 351 a to Bishop c2
that be working
maybe it's worth a try
okay worst-case scenario I'll have like
first of all I'm going to put the bishop
on e 2 and then D 3 and worst-case
scenario rep G 1 to try and survive
I doubt this is working but maybe it is
also of h5e three here here h5
that works unless it does work
to
now userupp g6 and
elaborate plans with a Z
you
oh my gosh I'm not gonna look at the
chat it's too insane
should be - I've
our ideas oh that's good move
that's a really good enough
take on g6
no this is bad
I'm so long time okay
and I activate the turbo mode
you
oh my gosh and even see Bishop e4
I think he's done give me more time
you
ah
you
this is really bad I'm trying to get
counterplay but it's not going to work
or is it gonna work
so you have any checks here he doesn't
have any checks but I'm getting flagged
and mated oh man he played Queen c2 and
flagged me I had queen h7 what's going
on in the final position
a good game well done enjoy good thing
that was casual well played
what did I miss feel like I missed a lot
of things I missed night 85 I was
embarrassing I probably should have
played some kind of better move
maybe Bishop III here Bishop III Queen
Bishop III Queen's egg b2 and don't have
Rick be one but maybe then like queen or
and maybe it's just better for black but
I had to be desperate and then this was
an interesting position but he played
well he he defended he got his pass to a
pond he's coached by Gautham chess I'm
so sad like the final position I have
queen h7g 7 and then
I can probably take
it's probably still losing for whites
but mmm it's tricky would be tricky
with Bishop f4 was a mistake do I play
the London no I played I played the
polar bear maybe the polar bear was a
mistake
when did I play Bishop f4
I never played Bishop f4 this game
yeah
did you see there is a queen ending in
the Junior Championship and the side
that was up two pawns lost it was some
Queen ending like this where like the
black King wasn't so sheltered and then
white one it was incredible because I
fell asleep but like right before it
happened just thinking game was over we
find that game broadcast
this Thalia right yeah this game I feel
so bad
because I was in the situation last week
I had a similar ending I was pushing for
a win and then lost and white missed a
win like somewhere at some point but
okay like this ending black is pushing
for a win pushing for a win and then
like that's annoying counterplay and
then black plays King g3 and then it's
just force mates an incredible thing
about this type of situation is when
you're playing black you just you you
forget the possibility that your
opponent could win and that's what
allows you to play a move like King III
thinking there's no way black could lose
she said afterward and said yeah yeah
she knew it was a draw
but I think she only found Queen c7
after King G through his plate she
didn't see it beforehand the original
idea was to play like Queen here and
Queen here but when you see a good move
look for a better move okay this is
another strategy sometimes when you lose
a tough game it's it's helpful to look
at other strong players and see their
blunders and realize that just
everyone's uh no one's perfect really
okay I've pretty fun pending challenges
and it's crashing me chess what is this
never seen this like gradient thing
before so beautiful okay a random number
time no not a random number let's just
pick someone is matrix still challenging
matrix was not patient enough but you
know who is patient enough impatient
duck I'm only accepting you because of
your username we'll see how patient he
is is he here hey he is here I'm gonna
play c6 cuz this is a move I discovered
recently idea of a5
that's a cool cool way to meet the
Polish and then idea is to play Knight
a6 and and Queen b6 and just everything
is on the queenside
if you don't know what to play against
the Polish this is actually a very
playable line and it's a bit annoying
for light because there's so much
pressure
you
that's all about controlling the center
there's any young people watching just
cover your eyes
starting like 30 seconds ago
um
okay we're getting some position nothing
developed have I accomplished anything
Queen b6 I just want him to play c3 now
I'll have accomplished something
maybe he'll play Bishop's III
upon
take it of course I take it
and now I probably have to start
developing
you
could just keep moving my queen places
let's develop d5
looks nice
like that emotes from Anna Ches list um
you know thanks for the follow
okay I have nice up I have a nice pawn
chain I'm up upon
I have no developments
have some developments I want to play
Bishop g4 next and then get some
something that resembles a London
- laid very much delayed London set up
Prague is really nice um it's like how
to describe it
it's so touristy like there's tourists
everywhere but it's clean it is good
his chest culture wait he hung up on I
can just take this for free
I think you forgot my Queen moves
horizontally now the food has been
amazing
Wi-Fi is decent
jibun see it because these might want to
play rugby one
I still have nothing developed consumed
who's 16 pushed pawns
be I play c5
'if I've can run into f4
by the way I might wrap it up very soon
just because I might be playing a blitz
tournament tomorrow I want to have some
sleep
and play this in this
feels like it's overextending but can't
easily win this pawn
this bishop is kind of stuck
time my bishop gets to see five
my pond will come to g5
Oh
Pleasant play Bishop d6 here
because now as kinga's tied down to his
knight and the knight is pinned to the
king if he tries to unpin himself i just
force him back think I'm winning a
knight unless I'm not many good Knights
I have this smooth double threat winning
material life is good I only have one
piece develop he wants to skewer me but
I can take the night with check
kingi for is tricky I was about to say
King G for it looks like I can play this
but then he wins everything so I have to
be careful play this castle
hmm
let's play Bishop t7
all I keep the work here sometimes I
have this
like to May them as quickly as possible
okay or win his rook he resigned too
quickly for me to take it
so impatience okay good game impatient
duck thanks for the patience in waiting
yeah that was an interesting
demonstration of the Polish how not to
develop any pieces and still win
it's funny the first wait a minute
the first nine moves that I played were
all in the queenside I completely
neglected my entire kingside and most
openings you're supposed to develop the
kingside first it's probably the longest
I've ever gone in any chess game without
touching a single piece on the kingside
nine moves while it moves and that
wasn't like I wasn't even trying to do
that it just kind of happened
okay uh do I play one more game so many
people
yes
anyone challenging me to one minute
to play longer chess
okay it's 11:47 p.m. I'll try and make
it till midnight well play this guy
because I think he's been waiting a
while I think he's in the chat somewhere
good luck
whatever your name is plea for he's
provisional from France
hmm
you can never underestimate France
as we learned
you made a twitch account because of me
that's so flattering
your name fat Jim 1389 a good luck
tomorrow
oh yeah I might play a tournament so I
keep forgetting I might play a
tournament tomorrow I don't know if it's
all in Joker sense at this point it's
probably like 45%
um okay we have a opening I love to
teach students it's called the two
Knights attack against the caro-kann so
many people walk into this this trap
Bishop f5 is actually the move which
walks into the trap a 95 and bucks in
trouble
if there's any efore players that don't
know what to play and caro-kann i highly
recommend this line starting it's just
it's just a two night's attack it's also
playable against the French defense if
pawns on e6 rather than c6 very playable
so many people go into this line
we black will play h6 I was still
playing that e5 and the line would go
Bishop h7 Queen H v g6 Bishop c4 and fun
stuff happens
chess with Chris is hosting with five
viewers thank you chess with Chris
I think I've hosted chess with Chris a
good handful of times over the last
month I appreciate the love
okay I still have this move
mate
he pretty much has to play g6 which is
so depressing
you could try Queen d5
but I think that's uh even worse than g6
I usually have this position with aplomb
in age six and nine not off the board
it's gonna be is very similar
g6 I'll give him my queen the Lord Ana's
huge fan from Germany
yeah thanks for the comment the Lord on
us okay now a lot of people would be
tempted to play Queen a3 here to
threaten mates and keeps initiative I
think the best move is Queen e2 because
it still has a threat but it's just
sneaky err we'll see if he sees the
threats
you
finally getting to see me play live the
shun McDermott's thanks for the sub shot
okay he didn't see the threats the whole
idea of Queen e2 is threatening they
take out seven
which I'm realizing normally when the
pawn is on each six you can take out
seven this is mate but in this case the
king can run I don't think it can hide
though as I have tea for life is good
yeah this is such a great line
like a good number my students have had
this like same same line like through
Queen e2 and night take f7 it should be
noted that there's so many ways black
and fall for a knight take F 797 oops
make it red
all of these are bad moves because of my
take out son but I could have to play
like this or this
yeah it's a pretty nasty line
so Shawn McDermott subbed and then
followed that's great
slightly out of order what do you think
the biggest barrier is from getting from
12 to 1300 to 1500 I would not say
I wouldn't say it's opening I wouldn't
say it's ingame I wouldn't say it's
middlegame
I'd say this it's experience it's just
about playing more games devoting more
hours to to playing to to reading books
do whatever you do then and in which you
best are most productively learn well
it's very small things which separate
maybe a few hundred points in rating and
normally it's just about putting in more
hours and keeping her staying passionate
about the game sorry - my opponent for
not moving not realizing it was my move
rough anneal rough anneal the rough
anneal sub before name sounds really
familiar
okay well this is gonna be a fun finish
oh this is gonna finish in double
checkmate
d4 d5 or Queens e5 and then double
checkmate
so beautiful thank you
I'm just gonna sit in an admirer this
for a moment
I posted a video a couple weeks ago it
was titled something like double Queen
sacrifice leads to double check mate and
someone commented that double check
mates doesn't really exist it's just one
check mate but it's double check and
it's me
so it's a bit confusing
anyway that was a fun line I just want
to end it there 15 moves each hit g5
Nathan telling me it's my move I just
didn't see that comment
oh you didn't suffer you hand followed
interesting but now you subbed
oh you did sub okay well thanks guys for
watching and sothing and donating thanks
for m singer for donating congrats to m
singer for beating me the only player to
beat me tonight's publish your research
on the double check please
what does that mean
yeah st. Louis chess club has great
content I would encourage people to
watch the broadcast of the juniors
happening this week with Roberts and in
Tata they were doing some good
commentary but I'm tired I know I have a
lot of pending challenges wait there is
some okay there is someone on YouTube
who just commented on a video wanting to
play me this is right before I started
streaming I responded as his comment I'm
wondering if he's watching
I don't know if it's possible to find
him little Plotkin wants to play
Lolo [ __ ]
I want to end this on note and not a bad
note I will play a little clocking in
the future
I'm just so tired it's been a long day
I'm gonna end it here we'll go to the
homepage some other people are streaming
maybe I'll raid someone um but I'm gonna
end it now and I will see you guys in
the future
bye